in the early hours on the 26th of June
Jordan Sweeney was on the prowl
captured here on CCTV eyeing up a
potential victim
the woman under the Green Arrow escaped
him but eventually he would find
sexually assault and then kill Zara
Alina
I'm livid I'm absolutely lifted
we're sad
we're heartbroken we're still
traumatized
a report has found that Zara's death
could have been avoided had probation
officers kept a proper eye on McSweeney
right okay he was released from prison
just nine days before killing Zara by
that point he'd racked up 28 convictions
yet he hadn't been classified as a
high-risk offender and wasn't arrested
even after probation breaches there were
mistakes
on every single level
throughout probation
Zara's life
was taken and probation had blood on
their hands
another death and another reason why
many women won't feel safe walking the
streets because like Sarah everard and
Sabina Nessa Zara was murdered by a
total stranger and women's rights
campaigners say it's yet another grave
reminder of the price women can pay for
failed government policy you can see
exceed blood in your hands yeah just
last week the probation service admitted
another failing it didn't properly
monitor Damien Bendel who killed his
pregnant partner and three children
whilst on probation it will send out a
message to women that you know you can
you can you can you can leave an abuser
and abuser could be put into prison but
they can come out and they can come back
for you and that is a terrible message
to be sending women
the government says serious issues in
both the McSweeney and bend or cases
were immediately addressed
but the Watchdog warns that until
standards are improved it's impossible
to say the public are being properly
protected Shimon Freeman Powell Sky News